(electronic beeps)
(screen dings)
- I'm Sage.
I'm a senior at a small university
in San Diego, studying
international relations.
And my dad is with me
here today. (chuckles)
- Clyde Taber. I lead a
faith-based nonprofit.
- [Crew Member] So Dad, what are you going
to be looking for today?
- Personality, desires,
interests, substance, et cetera.
- Height, maybe.
- Okay.
I'm 5'10", so-
- Probably.
I am an includer, so the
idea of excluding people
based on appearance is not natural.
(soft upbeat music)
(screen dings)
(soft upbeat music continues)
(heart dings)
Can I give you a hug?
- Sure.
- That's a left.
(bell trills)
(people laugh)
Can I give you a hug?
(bell trills)
(group laughs)
(heart dings)
Can I give you a hug?
(group laughs)
(bell trills)
It's a height thing.
Can I give you a hug?
- Sure, Absolutely.
(bell trills)
- I'm so sorry.
(heart dings)
- Can't say anything.
- You-
(heart dings)
- You're in, bro.
All right, you're in.
(heart dings)
You're in.
You are in.
(heart dings)
Yes, you're in.
Yep, you're in.
(heart dings)
All right. You are in, sir.
All right. Yes.
(heart dings)
Bring it.
Bring it in.
(heart dings)
(group laughs)
You were harder?
- Yeah.
- [Crew Member] How was that?
- Awkward.
Like everybody needs to be named and known
and seen and loved and
it's like, (bell trills)
gosh, killer.
(bell dings)
- [Crew Member] Dad is
gonna be judging you
based on your handshake and introduction.
- Good call.
That was brilliant.
(jazzy upbeat music)
- Hello, sir. It's very nice to meet you.
- What's your name?
- My name's Carter.
What's your name?
- Carter. I'm Clyde.
- You look a lot like Steve Martin.
- Wow. Okay, dude.
- Alright, that's a little long.
- [Sage] A little long.
- [Clyde] Okay. Sorry. Sorry.
Okay. Wow.
(heart dings)
- Hello? I'm Justin.
- Justin.
- Yes.
(heart dings)
- I'm Ryan.
Nice to meet you.
- Ryan, come on over.
(heart dings)
- Hi. I'm Al.
- Al?
- Nice to meet you.
(heart dings)
- How's it going, sir?
My name's Will.
- Hey Will. Clyde.
- How's it going, Clyde?
- Good to meet you.
(heart dings)
- Nice to meet you.
I'm Cade.
- Cade?
- Nice to meet you.
Good to meet you, go this way.
- Thailand like the country.
- I love that.
- Thank you.
- Oh, okay.
Dude, can I hug you?
- Yeah.
(group laughs)
- [Thailand] Give me a hug. Give me a hug.
- Rufus.
Go this way.
(heart dings)
- My name's Zach. It's nice to me you.
- Zach, go this way.
(heart dings)
- My name's Nico.
- Nico, can I give you a hug?
- Please.
(Sage laughs)
(bell trills)
- You give such nice hugs.
- My name is Melvin.
You have a beautiful smile, sir.
- Oh, Melvin, sucking it up, bro.
Yeah, you can come on in.
(heart dings)
- I'm Arthur.
- Arthur, can I give you a hug?
(bell trills)
Arthur, thank you.
You can go left.
- I thought Arthur was really cute...
With his purple shoes
and his foreign accent.
Yeah.
- Hi, my name's Jether.
- Jether?
- Yes.
- Clyde.
Go to the right.
(heart dings)
- Hi, my name is Ricky.
- Ricky?
- Yes.
Go to the left.
(heart dings)
She gave me some cues like
there's a couple guys in there.
And I was trying to think, okay
who are those couple of guys?
- My dad knows my type.
And I was like, oh, my dad will know.
He'll know.
And then I was shocked to say the least.
(bell dings)
- Nice to meet you again.
Your name again?
- Cade.
- I'm Ryan.
- Ryan.
- Zach.
- All right, Zach.
Tell me about you.
- I live in New York.
I'm a music business student at Syracuse.
I'm a musician.
I am a videographer in the
film and I do martial arts.
- So I'm currently going to
CSUOB majoring in chemistry.
I'm working toward becoming an EMT,
but the long term goal
would be a firefighter.
So that's what I would
see myself in five years.
- I studied finance and data analytics
at University of Maryland.
I currently work as a
public sector consultant.
- Okay, bro, you just said
University of Maryland.
Just go right?
(heart dings)
- Are you a Terp or something?
- I'm a Terp, bro.
- Are you a Terp?
Oh my God.
(Clyde laughs) No, I don't know
why that was very unplanned.
I don't know.
That was visceral.
- So my name is William.
I go to the University
of Maryland as well.
- Ah, nice one.
- I do. I'm currently-
- You do not.
- I do.
I'm a Terp.
- Which campus?
- College Park.
- Where do you live?
- Deal hall.
- Okay.
(heart dings)
(group laughs)
Maryland, yo, Terp.
Where'd you live?
I don't know.
That was about me. You kind
of called me out, so...
- I like to say that I'm
kind of good at golf.
So if you want to play golf sometime-
- All right.
- I've been looking for a partner, so-
- I suck at golf, but-
- I can teach you.
(Clyde laughs)
- Tell me about your family.
- My mom's from India.
We used to go every year.
She's amazing.
And I look up to her for
a lot of inspiration.
And my dad's a doctor.
I appreciate my
relationship a lot with him
now that I'm here.
- Tell me something about
your past dating life.
- I think I've tried
not to like throw myself
into relationships when like,
I don't think I've been ready for them.
But I think I'm at a
point in my life right now
where I am ready.
- Okay. So why are you on this episode?
- I'm on this episode
because I'm looking for love
and I'm trying to meet a nice dad.
Which I think I did.
(Clyde laughs)
- I'll be honest. I'm
here because like I said,
I just started my business so
I feel like I'm just trying
to get my face out there
as much as possible-
- Fair enough.
- I just love like talking.
- All right, dude. Can I give you a hug?
- Of course, man.
(bell trills)
- Good job. Good job.
Can I give you a hug?
- Oh yes, you can.
(bell trills)
- [Clyde] Thank you.
All right, bro.
Go to the right.
- Thank you. (heart dings)
Bro, I just swiped you right.
(heart dings)
Swiping right. (heart dings)
Appreciate it.
- Okay. Go, go, go, go.
- Thank you. (heart dings)
- Go to the right.
- Thank you
- All right.
- Thank you, sir.
- Yeah.
- Thank you so much.
- All right. All right.
- [Crew Member] Your dad had
a hard time narrowing it down.
I believe it. Yeah.
- Did I only eliminate one?
- [Crew Member] Two.
- Oh.
- I have an idea.
I have two questions for
each guy, the whole group.
Tell me something about
your spiritual/faith life.
And what's your opinion
about the border crisis
between Russia and Ukraine?
- Wow.
- Two questions.
Are we ready?
Boom.
- I go to the gym a lot.
And after the gym, I like
just meditating, doing yoga.
- Spirituality isn't the
biggest part of my life.
- I think it takes a bit more
of a broader spiritual sense,
but I think Christianity is the lens
through which I make sense of who God is.
- So I was raised as a
Buddhist, but nowadays at school
almost all of my friends are Christian.
So I'd say I'm pretty open-minded.
- I grew up Hindu, but I also
grew up in a Muslim country,
so I've learned a lot about Islam.
I've learned a lot about
different religions.
I think it's important
to have that perspective.
- For me, my whole family's Christian.
Everybody's Christian.
I'm also a Christian as well.
- And question two, I'm not a big fan
of Russia's moves in Ukraine.
I think it's mostly about Crimea, right?
And just think they should
kind of leave them alone.
Russia's already big enough.
- Russia, I know they're
trying to pull a false flag
on Ukraine and try to say like,
people are attacking Russia
so they could, you know, attack
and cause like a huge problem in Europe.
As far as I remember this,
Russia is invading Ukraine.
- I'm pretty ignorant on the topic,
but I would be happy to have you educate.
- Personally, I don't
know that much about it.
I could learn and should learn more.
- I don't know much about it.
- I don't know enough to comment
and so I don't want to.
- I do not know much about the conflict
to make an informed opinion,
so I will not answer that question.
- I also would not like
to talk outta my ass.
- Sorry. (bell trills)
You're to the left. (bell trills)
You're to the right. (heart dings)
You can go left. (bell trills)
You can go right. (heart dings)
To the right. (heart dings)
All right, bro. You can
go right. (heart dings)
You can go right. (heart dings)
All right. To the right. (heart dings)
Okay. (Clyde claps)
- [Crew Member] Do you
feel like out of these guys
there's a good match for your daughter?
- I do.
- [Crew Member] Okay.
- Hey, how'd you do?
- Oh, like my inner OCD kinda-
- What?
- Kicked in.
I just had so many questions.
- Okay.
- It's hard.
You know, when I think about life, dating,
I think my biggest thing about dating is
the kind of guy you date is probably
the kind of guy you could marry.
I'm not saying this is a marriage thing.
- Okay.
- But the direction you
start in is probably
the direction you keep going.
So you wanna date the kind of people
that have that potential.
I think you will like this person.
I think you're gonna find
him handsome. (bell dings)
- Okay.
- And I think you may have a connection
on the faith/spiritual level. (bell dings)
- Okay.
- And there's a surprise, a bonus feature.
- Great.
- That will wait to tell you
the third thing about him.
- Oh, this is great.
Okay.
(upbeat music)
- Hey.
(both laugh)
- What's your name again?
- My name is Will.
- Will, nice to meet you.
- You nice to meet you too.
- Okay. What's the surprise.
- I don't know.
I'm assuming it's cuz I go to
the University of Maryland.
- Ah. Maryland boy for Dad.
- But are you from Maryland?
- No, my dad grew up Maryland.
I've road tripped to Maryland.
- Which part?
- Couldn't tell you.
I was 12.
I ate a lot of crabs.
- I can show you around.
- Yeah.
Okay. I'll have to see
you next time I'm there.
I'll be in New York this summer, so-
- You can take me there.
- Okay. There you sounds good.
Awesome. Well, great to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, too.
Can I get your number and Instagram?
- Yes. Oh I can put my Instagram in.
- Okay.
- Definitely a surprise
cause he was shorter than me,
but then the Maryland thing
made a little more sense
and he does have really
beautiful eyes, so we'll see.
- [Crew Member] Do you
think your dad chose someone
that he would like to hang out with?
- Probably.
It sounded like he was really
getting along with everyone.
- I just was hanging out
with some of the guys
and I'd love to get to know them more
because they're all
interesting, amazing, creative.
And encountering people
and learning their stories
is just part of the richness of life.
- I love my dad.
He makes everyone feel very loved.
- [Crew Member] And will we
give Dad's choice a shot?
- Yeah, sure.
He has my number so it's up to him.
But he seems like a really
nice guy, so we'll see.
I'm like super open to meeting
and hanging out with anyone.
Yeah.
(clarinet playing)
- Oh.
- Oh, together?
(clarinet playing)
(Will and Sage laugh)
- One, two, three, four, five, six.
- That's the end.
- It's only like a-
(group laughs and claps)
- Would have been a great day.
- It's like a minute and a half song.
- You did great.
- Thank you.
- All right, guys.